Say we wanted to develop a randomized algorithm for the vertex cover problem,
and let's go ahead and start off by looking at our
2-approximation to the vertex cover problem.
And if you remember from before,
the basic algorithm for this was
while we still have edges that are uncovered,
we take an uncovered edge and then we add both endpoints to the cover.
Now we're going to change this around
by choosing randomly here,
that is we choose a random uncovered edge,
and we're also going to choose the endpoint that we add to the cover at random.
So instead of adding both, we add one or the other at random,
and that's how we develop a randomized algorithm
based on this 2-approximation vertex cover.
Now if we run this on an N-vertex graph,
which we know has a unique minimum vertex cover of size K.
My question then is how long does the randomized algorithm run in the worst case?
Is the algorithm guaranteed to finish after
K iterations, 2K iterations, or N-1 iterations?
And check whichever the 3 you think is most correct.